you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens what's up everybody
welcome back to e3 2016 from the game
spot co-op stage scout roadies out there
what's up a round of applause Oh Scott
Roeder make a PlayStation games happen
now this segment is why playstation is
terrible now I want to be roast some
kind of funny Greg Miller that the pride
of Long Island calma rarities that's the
pyramid oh uh you somebody you like how
long were you doing this you kind of
Buck what should I say like it's pretty
much that's the pier when Tim Gettys
that's the producer / to do sir Nick
scarpino guys we've come to the end of
e3 it's over done we did it show our
time on the game spot stage is drawing
to a close so we figured just like last
year we would preemptively man pick the
game of the show why not we have acute
nixed you haven't been on a lot of
segments I see I assume you're out there
you've seen a million games I have seen
every single solitary game that I wanted
to see on the show floor this year which
is y'all ready all I did was stand over
like y'all ready lightly wet in a
cabbage odd and I'm they know I'm seen a
bunch tomorrow seen a bunch on Thursday
as well very excited about that but why
let that stop us great we've never we
had all our Wars out here I'm so happy
it went away I all gave one away to what
you give it to I gave it to Batman tell
tones bounty upon horizon right up then
we have the game over to figure out so
you guys still has plenty to give out
yeah Tim here's the thing about this
yeah I feel a lot of my choices I have
locked in and things that have impressed
me done things for me made me feel it in
the tingly yep yep yep you haven't seen
Zelda yet I haven't seen Zelda which is
hard for me cuz it's right there and I
can feel the Zelda I can smell the Zelda
yeah you're having 20 20 minutes 40
minutes 30 minutes away from playing it
I've seen the trailer happy about this
what it was i given you have you talked
to people about it very little don't see
it everyone is I'll beulah hope and
shoot it peter brown sauce didn't talk
to him I talked to him I've heard good
things there's a little of stealing the
internet people are excited about it
yeah the trailer I have a lot of
questions okay how the question what is
it oh I'm not ready to give it one of my
pad did kind of funny approved
David the show yeah faces yeah not ready
to okay I assume the later today I will
be ok right now that spot I'm giving to
tentatively to horizon zero dawn again
Wow last year I gave it my my game the
show this year still impressed me that
game looks fun as hell yeah it's a game
I actually want to play I'm gonna get in
and want to get all over it so I also
saw the trailer for Zelda and I do
there's a lot of similarities between
the two yeah and to be completely honest
as of right now before playing zelda I'm
more impressed with horizons so Dan oh
it says it's pretty shocking you were
like oh gee get your hands on it though
I know but but still I think I I horizon
consistently impresses me alright dolled
up from the trailer so far yeah it's
what I expected ok which is not bad
Skyrim Zelda yeah expect but again it's
kind of like though you always talk
about the fallout 3 fallout 4 thing
right where it's like I kind of wanted
to be blown away by Zelda again in an
hour everything can change but I left
that spot ok there is another villas
confirmed let's Detroit c-calm human
that is the problem I did I did the
Detroit become human segment here and I
almost ate game David one of my faces
but the problem is it's the same thing I
feel like this is our first year Eddie
three it looks for me my first time in
five or six years or I'm actually gonna
play games tomorrow and see things and
walk around and so there's things I want
to check in on before I just give it to
detroit detroit an amazing presentation
but i need to know what's happening in
Lego dimensions I need to know what's
happening it's the NSA to the caves not
here but we have to talk can I give a
trailer one of my kind of funny approve
things not in the running for my game of
the show but one of my faces see that's
my thing cuz like obviously looking at
the the press conference last night
there's a whole bunch of amazing looking
games crash bandicoot when I give the
moment of the show undeniably for me
yeah just crash bandicoot i'm not gonna
give it one of these yeah absolutely not
yeah right the resident evil 7 i think
it's super super awesome i'm not gonna
give it not gonna give it one you know
spider-man undeniably I'm sure that if I
could play or see more actual gameplay
of it it would get one of these but
because we're not know
Detroit though that's a game that I
wouldn't necessarily be into and they
sold me on it and I think that's why
they deserve one of these okay cuz I'd
you give it a sense Detroit is the
horizon of this year for me well last
year I would have thought that what game
would have been interesting to me but
totally what Detroit very sad for it but
you're giving horizon ahead today see
right yeah because they're continually
impressed okay you're making sure you
making sure no last year they were my
wild card is what I'm saying Wow car
didn't respect him call away where your
head's at horizon already has one the I
think horizons the game of the show as
well I think we should give it to it
again uh I think I'll be funny one and
also it's just I think head and
shoulders above a lot what's going on
here on principle alone and I know that
people you know you know they were
playstation fanboys and I don't really
care I'm not gonna lose literally any
sleep about it is uh I'm gonna give this
principally for some principle alone
days gone get pays gone yeah see that's
one of the ones where I got one I like
what I saw of dead rising but days gone
seems to be really what I'll be after a
narrative driven I'm running through
Nick what are you doing Kevin we need
the camera kit in about 10 minutes got
it I get me Kevin why is he always ruin
of the shows this is totally your fault
you know it get up here and apologize
get up here and take your day if you're
gonna look the wide camera to apologize
don't get up in there and you apologize
just say you're sorry maui like
murdering though I didn't mean it um so
Dave Scott definitely getting getting
one I think it looks awesome yeah Ben's
coming out party I'm really pulling for
those every single I think that they
haven't had a chance to flex our muscles
in a very long time working with others
IP and swatches so I'm gonna give it to
them as well and the third one I'm gonna
say it until further notice another one
that I want in my discussions of things
that caught me off guard that I might
have no interested but now I do I'm not
a Ghost Recon wildlands keep anything
but we saw that watching that I was like
oh like I thought you had an awkward
trailer last year and now you're showing
this demo of a world I would like to go
play with friends I don't like
get lost yeah nickel helps sell parts to
the home on South Park yeah yeah it's
gonna be aa I'm giving south but I'm
considering it South Park just because
of the title just for the jeedai hide
all that they have oh yeah why not that
Batman or the two that I am most
interested in seeing Batman yeah I'm not
gonna see Batman cuz I'm not scheduled
for it but go and get yourself what's
that he was gonna scheduled appointment
I thought so hey that's the other Batman
scheduled out there for you guys get it
excited see that I'm excited see days
texts such as well oh yeah days I got a
big fan of your big fan big fan of that
that's you just shooting b-roll what
he's doing out there trout think I'm
trying to give up what I'm missing here
cuz there has to be that's my Compton
I'm gonna break out my phone cuz I want
to look you're gonna give a less party
last guardian / garden does not deserve
any of your awards glassy you already in
deserving and your brothers on the
knuckles for children Oh long no
definitely not I'm excited I get to play
it your witty tomorrow yeah i think so
that's exciting I think we have a lot
more to say in the coming days about
like where are things all why are you
but arts are we doing what we did last
year so a few of it which was aa run
inform you should flare into the ground
or pretty much I'm just picking a game
of the show with cisco even big war are
we not picking a game is sure okay
that's the case and I've over persona 5
you again cuz it's not even like
playable though but it's there so let's
just throw a couple of on there what do
you think I say we wait put it up there
one away so we need to i want you to see
persona I think of Zelda I didn't see
last guardian colonies to see I'm sure
everything then true by the way yeah
late a quick little unassociated tidbit
I can't I love burst so much i love year
since 2011 Evita is nowhere on the show
for no [ __ ] no Willie not anywhere over
there now one betta kiosk on Sony's uh
not alone that's no good there's only
two meters in this building but they're
both in these men's pockets I wish 3
i've designed more than 2 meters today
Tim all right maybe one day when they
bring back that crash bandicoot you'll
sign something but until then you have
to worry about it but it's out there
good uh what you got here Byron a
special edition man hello scrolls online
man Dishonored 2 looks great and it's
not her to looks great yes you know I
was saying I was saying no to resident
evil earlier but I do think they showed
enough for me to consider giving it cuz
I disorder i don't like I don't get
smart of me cuz i was just a trailer
yeah I feel like resident evil
especially cuz we've had the kitchen
thing before but thing there's enough
context to potentially give it one of
mine I'll tell you what like right now
if I had to vote gaming show I'd votes
house parts oh yeah yeah great I've been
reminded of that exists like this
because she goes the South Park I think
of true to the awesome I can only wait
for practice butthole yeah you gotta say
we talked about Greg is your mic dumb we
finally here with a call Moriarty
hopefully up there this game huh Sammy's
back yeah then yeah I've got a war
getting days gone we'll talk about us
gonna ditch for you I want to see some
stuff though yeah I think we should we
should married it oh yeah that's my
questions how do you guys know I you
just roam around and figure out what's
playable in the show floor like based on
appointment like is it up good way of
all do we know that i don't know but i
doubt it I mean we have a bunch of
appointment behind glass or subway logic
you're gonna spend extra time outside of
those equipments trying to find oh they
was trying to do that follows or not now
I played I played you that your favorite
so you should have appointments for what
you want to see cut should be there
that's why you're seeing all the sex
minigames yeah yeah that would beat cop
is set around Kagura is gonna be all you
nice good out of there you're welcome
well you all right so right now confirm
what you have or are giving a head to
nothing yet Detroit's the only one
confirmed horizon has the tentative that
might get stolen by Zelda horizon in
days gone all right and I've only given
it to Batman but I have a bunch of
things and bunch of pokers in the fire
for me too yeah I think South Park for
sure i have to give one to cuz i loved
it it's what I love the southpark game
play then
superheroes you know bring all that
together that world I'm in for that good
all right ladies and gentlemen that's
where we are right now it's game of the
show we haven't picked one yet but you
can be sure that we will you won't see
it here on gamespot com if you're
watching if you're watching on youtube
com such kind of funny game you will see
it there remember it's Wednesday and
Thursday you want me to go there you
just wave it's fine don't worry about it
I thought they're editing all together
they're not doing any more are the
Eddystone you don't know yours for
jogging around you're worse than cash
anyways we'll put on one's worse than
company huh well one of our vinyl pigs
there but don't worry there's plenty
more here on gamespot com if that's
where you are are all of our crazy
friends from this crazy internet culture
are doing crazy things here well we jerk
off all over the [ __ ] place Oh
another game already not literally Nick
Oh figured it early figuratively jerk
off with just pure joy like slowly night
last night like Sony did slapping
everybody in the face am the gifts are
great by the last yeah that's very good
we're good till next time ladies and
gentlemen it's been a pleasure to serve